Bob Woodward author of the best-selling
commanders on page 3 14 of your new book
it says that none of the Chiefs was
itching for a fight meeting the Joint
Chiefs of Staff they did not want an
offensive operation if there was any
other honorable way out for the United
States if they didn't want that how come
we didn't hear more from them during the
debate leading up to the war well the
the Chiefs are really not a
decision-making body general Powell is
the chairman is kind of their
representative to the inner circle at
the White House and those debates are
closed and they try to keep them from
coming out it's a very secretive process
I the Chiefs met once or twice with Bush
from the period of the invasion of
Kuwait up to the beginning of the war
and as I recount in there at one point
it was general McPeek who is the air
force chief kind of told bush with the
consequences of this might be in writing
this book and I know you talk about how
you write it in the beginning do you
tell at any point exactly who you talk
to I mean have you admitted to say
spending time his Newsweek said lots of
hundreds of hours with Colin Powell well
there's been lots of speculation and of
course people try to figure out where
information comes from it's my job to
preserve the confidentiality of the
sources what's nice is this book has
been out for a month now little over a
month in fact no one has stood up to
dispute any of it and people have been
quite silent on that fact and people who
in particular are skeptical about this
method have gone around and checked and
found out that it's accurate were you
surprised that the president reappointed
Colin Powell so rapidly yes no in in
fact if you really look at the Bush
presidency I think it's quite evident
that in the two and a half years of the
administration that the most successful
things that is the
operation in the Gulf War I have been
operations really overseen by Colin
Powell I was talking to somebody the
other day in the White House who said
you take away Panama and the Gulf and
the Bush presidency is really reduced to
a lagging economy and lots of
uncertainty about a legislative agenda
so in a sense I think you could argue
that Bush needs strong military man
needs to identify him as a symbol of
these successful operations you were in
the Navy yes sir for how long five years
where were you stationed stationed
aboard the presidential flagship for two
and a half years which was a relocation
site aboard a small light aircraft
carrier that was converted they no
longer have these because they realize
how vulnerable they were I been on a
destroyer off the coast of Vietnam and
in the western Pacific for a year and a
half in the Pentagon for the last year
would you do in the Pentagon worked in
communications for the Secretary of the
Navy and the Chief of Naval Operations
did do you form certain ideas about what
you were going to find here in the
commander's because of that experience
well that was I was really at the lowest
officer level or you know what the
lowest three grades of officer and what
you see there there at that level is not
what goes on in this book at the highest
level so you get a sense of the military
you get a sense of the tedium Vietnam
was going on when I was in the service
and became very disenchanted with the
war I think like lots of people i don't
know i can't quite relate that
experience to working on this as a
reporter are you surprised that so many
people would talk to you wear our
uniforms
well i was lucky i started to work on
this in right after bush was elected in
1988 and the idea was to do one of these
institutional books the millet the
military the Pentagon like I had done
the CIA or the Supreme Court I got to
know the people there really got into
their business the budget debates and
the weapon systems debates that were
going on and the Berlin Wall came down
in 89 everyone thought the military was
irrelevant the Pentagon what you know
why do a book on it so in a sense i had
the field to myself I think I was the
only person doing a book on the Pentagon
at that time then Panama and the Gulf
came along and I knew the people in the
process so I hope I demonstrated to
these people that I was interested in
their business and took it seriously and
took them seriously so when it got down
to pulling the trigger I was able to
deal with them who do you find easier to
get to talk someone who is a civilian
political type or the military good
question it's like everything else it's
like in government or journalism its
personality dependent i would say you
will find some military officers willing
to talk immediately some never same with
the civilians I you can't help but when
you read the book know that I don't even
know if you're willing to admit this it
Admiral crowd talk to you I'm just not
going to talk about sources what what's
nice about and I and I think there's
been lots of this apprehension about
what this method is I talked to when I
say I talked to hundreds of people I
mean that and that's probably a low
number
there's a whole part of this book that I
wrote that is not in the book about the
regular business of the military
services and the Pentagon and you know
what I do for instance you mentioned it
Admiral Crowe who was Paul's predecessor
as chairman of the JCS I he had this
relationship with Marshall akram a off
who was his counterpart in the Soviet
Union and he spent a lot of time on that
crowd talked to dozens and dozens of
people about it he spent weeks and
months on that relationship my sources
on what are just a couple of paragraphs
and the book probably involved three or
four dozen people and kind of setting
aside the question of whether I talk to
him or whether I didn't and it became so
clear what the nature of the
relationship with the Soviet counterpart
was how important it was to him that
it's irrefutable this is going to be
tough free to answer them on the fan
stitute page 219 page 290 to know will
be tougher e to answer we tough for us
to get an answer on page 2 92 talking to
reporters for so long in such close
quarters was a dangerous and foolish
thing to do Powell new meaning Colin
Powell and any junior public relations
officer knew it and later you he's
referring to general Dugan yes the Air
Force chief who took a group of
reporters with him I think three
reporters to Saudi Arabian spent four
days with them and that what i was when
i was there other points in the book
where you you quote some but coach
general palace saying and you shouldn't
talk to the press basically the day when
you're an officer in the service that
you ought avoid that and I know I that's
not true i mean he says in there
he is asserting that it's foolish to
spend four days with the reporter what
Powell says and his attitude is I think
described in some detail in the book is
that the press is very important and you
can get the operation right the military
operation but as soon as it's over or as
soon as certain phases of it or over you
have to turn to television you have to
turn to the press because that is the
medium that is going to explain it to
the people so he's not hostile I didn't
mean it was hostile so much is that you
just got the impression that he thought
that general doing shouldn't have talked
and shouldn't spend all that time and I
wanted to ask you why he spent so much
time with you if he thought that's a bad
idea you can ask that question 10
different ways and and give me sodium
pentathol and torture me and I'm not
going to talk about sources and it's not
out of a feeling of being coy or isn't
this cute or let's add to the mystery
it's that government has become so good
at public relations and they all have
specialists all of the services even the
chairman of the JCS is a public
relations team that works for him and
they put out a certain version of
reality and it's incomplete I think the
book demonstrates that I think my other
books demonstrate that and you have to
get around that you have to go deeper
you have to understand you have to cross
check and then cross check the cross
check and you can only do that by having
many many good sources not one or ten or
40 but hundreds then when you do that
you get a picture that is much fuller
much
complete when was the last word written
for this book oh that's good question i
think the middle of march i may have
done some tinkering with it in galleys
in fact I did so I guess let's see the
book came out early May sign off here as
March 14 1991 that's right but I think I
was still doing some work in April
certainly up to the beginning of April
how long in total time did you work on
the book and did you work on full time I
worked out at two and a half years
virtually full-time most of my energy
went into working on this book and not
at the Washington Post where I'm an
editor do you work at home where you
working on office both would you rather
talk to one of these sources that you
have in this book by phone or in person
again it's personality dependent it's
amazing some people are so comfortable
over dinner in my house or lunch at
their house other people are much more
comfortable on the phone it's
interesting and you can get them on the
phone there are not lots of people
around and in most cases hopefully no
one else around and if you do it in
unusual times of the day the weekend you
have much better opportunity again you
have to fight you have to do your
reporting in a way that accommodates the
person you're talking to you tape record
your energies some of them I do with
permission of the people involved some
of the very good sources allowed me to
tape recorded the interviews and with
the agreement that it was all on
background and deep background and that
I would not identify it but by having a
tape I was able to get a much fuller
picture and of course this will go into
my archives and someday in 50 or 75
years the historians can go back and say
well who was the source who were the
sources for the
and even though the historians have done
some complaining about this book at that
point 50 75 years from now they're going
to be able to go back and they're going
to be amazed at the level of
documentation and cross-checking and the
nature of the primary sources and the
proximity to the events where do you
intend to put all those tapes I don't
know no plan really do you sign an
agreement with someone when you record
an interview no do you know so it's up
to all done on trust in faith and if you
set a limit you say 50 to 75 years I
mean at some point went on I guess I
don't know it's not something I've given
a lot of thought to I have all of my for
each of my books and projects everything
filed away quite systematically and
somebody is going to be able to go back
and do this I don't know exactly I
really haven't thought about it when you
work on a book like this how many people
work with you had two full-time
assistance the people that you give
credit to in the front of the right bill
powers and Marc Solomon and what role
does a bill powers jr. former aide to
Senator John Chafee Republican of Rhode
Island play well he worked for me for
three years actually before I begin the
book and bill is a real wizard very
smart man very good writer very
meticulous somebody who helped me
immensely with the writing and the
organizing of the filing system as did
Marc Solomon worked for the last year
almost a year and a half on the project
and did editing transcribing of tapes it
was a collegial effort among the three
of us any of the others that you worked
with doing in the interviewing they did
some of the interviewing none of the
major interview there are people that
just wouldn't talk to you as I say in
the beginning
George Bush was not interviewed I asked
to interview him and he threw his press
secretary Marlin Fitzwater declined kind
of an interesting letter Fitzwater sad
that Bush was not giving interviews and
this was while the war was going on in
the Gulf but he was not giving
interviews during the war and he also
said that he wouldn't give that the
president wouldn't give interviews for
books would a policy I was not aware of
because of the books commercial value if
you really think about it doesn't make a
whole lot of sense because certainly
gives interviews to newspapers and
magazines and television and they're all
commercial enterprises but that's what
he said to Ben Bradley and dick Snyder
the best friends a writer could have the
dedication of the book how come you
decided to do that those two this time
you're really following every page and
Ben Bradley's the editor of the post and
has been my boss for 20 years and pick
Snyder's the head of Simon & Schuster
and they've published all of my books
going back to All the President's Men on
Watergate and you know you don't is a
writer reporter author you don't do
these things in a vacuum and it's very
important to have serious support at the
top and they've always given me that
serious support and sometimes it's been
tough sometimes these you know the work
has been criticized we've been denounced
they are both keenly aware of how I work
and how careful it's it is and they're
willing to take the heat and have always
supported it if you don't have that you
don't have a publisher or an editor in a
newspaper really doesn't I
could write these letters to my family
and read this information in letters to
my family and it would have no
dissemination so they're kind of the
backbone of it all are you surprised
that it's number one both the New York
Times Washington Post and I'm sure other
bestseller list it is nationally no I
guess on one hand I'm not surprised
because the wars and the use of force is
a very emotional issue in this country
and people are even people who are
wildly enthusiastic about it know that
we killed lots of people and we risked a
great deal in both Panama on the Gulf
the people who are passionately opposed
to it I think often are the people who
want more information on it I think both
sides actually want more information on
it and i have found be when you write a
book like this you get calls and letters
and talk to people and the war is a big
deal the average person who might buy or
read this book I think realizes the what
we're risking how we're defining not
just a foreign policy or the Bush
presidency but how we were are defining
what this country is and there is a deep
awareness of the trauma of Vietnam among
a whole whole age range in this country
and in a sense this is the other side of
Vietnam I think people feel good about
it but still feel quite hesitant and not
exactly where it all fits in and they
want to know more and happily almost all
of the information in this book is new
it really takes you to the table and you
sit down and for an hour long meeting
you you can see what the president said
and what general Powell said Secretary
of Defense Cheney said what the by play
was what the sequence was what
intelligence they had what the
anticipated hazard of some sort of
military operation or small or large
move in the sequence of events so you
normally don't have been available so I
think people care about it they want to
know more a couple of details in the
acknowledgments section you have a
paragraph here you said above that you
say that no one can attempt to write
about the Pentagon our military affairs
and not acknowledge the exceptional work
of patrick totter Michael Gordon RW
Apple gender and others in the New York
Times why did you feel a need to reach
out to the New York Times well I mention
all the people at the Washington Post
also and that other newspapers and news
organization New York Times does
particularly those three reporters do an
exceptional job and they have some of
the information first at times and they
analyze it very well and when you are
totally immersed in a subject like this
you really have to give them credit next
paragraph television news who assisted
me greatly Pentagon reporters such as
Fred Francis of NBC David Martin of CBS
and Bob Zelnick of ABC often have the
story first any examination of the news
coverage of recent military crises would
show how serious and comprehensive their
work is someday these reporters will
sieve the will receive the credit they
deserve again why did you feel the need
to do that well well particularly in the
gulf war that was home writing this book
during the war phase and really putting
the last part of it I was kind of undead
line for months at a time
and I tried to start early in the day in
about 6 30 when the news would come on i
take a break and go watch the news to
see what happened that day and i watched
as much as i could of all three networks
they come on at different times and you
can bounce around and they're good and i
knew a lot of what was going on behind
the scenes or some of them i had a sense
of what the war was its cadence the
nature of the operations and so forth
and these people are really plugged in
and anyone who watches those shows
probably don't realize how good the data
is that they're getting and i really
felt they I should say that because I
knew that to be true now in the book you
mentioned often that people were
watching CNN but in the credits you
don't say anything about seeing I live
in the district of columbia and not able
to get CNN at home so I didn't watch CNN
so I it was not something like I could
measure personally and so I didn't say
anything about it we also wrote by the
end I mean in the end of your project
some were very unhappy to hear from me
with one more request for more
information did you really have people
get upset with you yes they used the
words that I can't repeat on your show
not anger at what I was doing or me I
don't think they were angry that I was
coming back again and again there the
first week of the Gulf crisis there's
about a 60-page section in the book and
I did interviews for that over months
and what I went back to some people a
dozen or two
about specific meetings what were
attitude what was said what was the
sequence because the sequence becomes
very important and a lot of these people
were quite busy because they were
involved in Desert Shield or the war
itself and they were not happy to hear
from me again and my argument was I've
talked to somebody else and there's
another little piece here i'm going to
verify there's something I don't
understand not sure I understand your
exact precise attitude on this it's done
very very carefully and when you are a
participant in that process of having
somebody come back again and again and
again sometimes I felt like Colombo just
one more question in two more questions
I need to talk again and you know that's
frustrating to people to me it's
essential when you were in the Navy did
you do intelligence work you know I did
you have a clearance of any kind yes I
had a top-secret cryptographic clearance
doing the highest level and the most
classified and the most sensitive
communications functioning but that it
those are not intelligence clearances
and if you know about the way they
compartmentalized information they
compartmentalized it in a way that that
you have to have separate clearances for
intelligence the reason I ask is that
when I read the section on the war I
kept learning things that obviously were
classified I mean even locations of
situation rooms and what the rooms look
like inside and the kind of photography
that they were able to pick up on
satellites and things like that as you
were doing this and listen to people
tell you this were you saying here so
why are these people who are obviously
cleared giving me this information big
people well I must tell you the
there's a lot I left out I think I
presented it in a way you might argue
it's classified i would say nothing
vital was given away I've had no
complaints from anyone and the people
who know the most about this that there
is a way to cut around the edges to
describe some of the rooms and general
techniques and give a very broad
overview but not compromise anything and
i think i found that line in doing the
in the 70s and the 80s i did a lot of
work on the CIA and intelligence and
learned a good deal about it and i think
there is a way to present that data so
it's new so it's detailed but does not
compromise things actually i was asking
it from the other angle whether or not
as you heard people describing to you
classified information that you knew is
classified did you ever say to yourself
why are they doing this i mean they're
compromising or could potentially
compromise the situation because of the
information they're giving me well I
piece a lot of it together and I
eventually get to a point where I think
I know a lot more than that i'm going to
print so it's not is if somebody is
saying oh here let me tell you about
this i already know let me give you an
example i mentioned in there that there
was a black top secret program for
knocking out the electrical capability
in iraq very very sensitive never really
had been utilized before and it it's the
sort of system where the Iraqis would
not know what hit them in fact they
would not even know whether their
electrical system had been attacked I
give no details subsequently to the war
one of those very good New York Times
reporters that I credited in the back
wrote a story describing some of the
technique of dropping these little
filaments
the electrical power grid system in Iraq
that really is knocked out the
electrical system to a level that
perhaps know when they anticipated now I
did not give that because the various
people I talked to said don't describe
the technique I just gave say there was
some technique here with no details no
description of the weapons delivery
system or even whether it was a weapon
no indication of how many targets would
be hit nothing just that it existed what
do you think of the one pardon what did
you think of the war still haven't fully
sorted out my own feelings on it is you
work on a book like this and get totally
immersed in it I have often found that
it's best to take my own sentiments and
conclusions and get them in my back
pocket and keep them there and I tend to
do that some of the reviewers of the
book of complained that I don't analyze
and take a stand or a position on things
and that's that just the way I do it I
feel more comfortable and quite frankly
i think that the sources from who may
have their own perspectives or an
analysis or policy goals see that i come
as a neutral and that I want to hear
what they have to say and that their
ideas and their analysis will be
presented in the book before I forget it
you were talking about sources earlier
and then again I've got to ask you the
obvious the deep throat question we use
some day reveal deep throat in history
yes when he is deceased when he is
decisions not when you're a deceased
when he's deceased who's going to go for
a lighted I alive well that's in again
no one planes for their own death and I
certainly fall in that category and I've
always said that I will reveal after he
is deceased how's this book doing
compared to all the other books you've
written well I've been fortunate that
all of the other books have been number
one bestsellers also so this is where
this book is is at the moment is it
selling more or less than those
bestsellers you get a sense of which
well the these books sell for a long
period of time many months and I don't
have numbers on it the people I've
talked to at Simon & Schuster the
publisher and independent people say
it's out selling any book in the country
now quite a bit it is a recession
economy and books are expensive and the
people who are in the book business
would love to be selling more books but
when it's out selling any other book by
such a great deal you know I don't know
what measure you have beyond that All
the President's Men final days the
Brethren wired veil and now this book
which of all these books did you get the
biggest kick out it is it obvious that's
like no obvious in what sense obvious
that the the big seller All the
President's Men one that had the most
impact on or the final days I mean well
actually All the President's Men did not
outsell the others I think the one that
is sold the most so far is the one on
the Supreme Court the Brethren sold in
hardback about twice what All the
President's Men so I think each one of
these books it's like having at least so
far six children you
realize the strengths and weaknesses and
each of them you have an affection for
each of them they represent a certain
time in your life a certain commitment
certain effort to understand some part
of in the most of these cases government
and I I guess I tend to spend some time
reflecting on the deficiencies of all of
them and they they all have deficiencies
and trying to make each one better i
think some of the deficiencies have been
applied to the latter books but not
totally which one was the hardest hmm
good that's the hardest in the sense of
gathering the information you know
getting those sources to talk to you
I think the book unveil on the CIA
because the CIA is an institution that
plays a very ambiguous game with other
countries in the world within the
federal system in the national
government the people who were in the
CIA in a sense have been trained to
manipulate in DC so getting the straight
story getting to know bill Casey the
head of the CIA at the time I was doing
the book that probably was the most
difficult as a reporting effort next
book no immediate plans I'm going to
spend some time working at the post and
see what happens what is your job at the
post now assistant managing editor head
of the Investigative Division unit at
the paper what do you think of
investigative journalism right now good
question too I don't know whether
investigative journalism is really
different from journalism that it is
always described as a subspecies I tend
to think that it is just more thorough
more in-depth basic reporting so I try
not to separate it out in any way these
books that I have done and they would
not be described as investigative no one
has their hand in the cookie jar no
one's going to go to jail it is an
attempt to get as close as you can to
government and describe how it works I
would not call it investigative i'm not
sure i would call even the watergate
books investigative I
call the reporting for the Washington
Post on Watergate investigating you know
that over the years since All the
President's Men the Watergate reporting
that you're constantly referred to as
the you and Carl Bernstein is the people
that spurred interest in journalism and
schools interestingly enough that's not
true what's not really that we spurred
interest in journalism people have
looked at the enrollment journalism the
interest in it really grew out of the
Vietnam War not out of Watergate to a
certain extent i'm a product of the
response to vietnam and how that the
feeling i had that the government had
gone astray and journalism was one field
to enter where you could examine
government independently what do you
think of journalism overall today and
the curve since you've started in this
business well I i think it's like i
would analyze any of my books the pluses
and minuses i think journalism doesn't
overall a very good job i think often
were too caught up in the daily story
we're too much attention is given to how
can we move the story ahead on a 24 hour
cycle and journalism gives a lot of
attention to trying to describe what's
going to happen political pundits will
sit around and say who are the democrats
going to nominate in 92 who's going to
win will bush keep quail on the ticket
all kinds of speculative things and then
there are a whole group of journalists
and pundits who will sit around and say
this is what should have happened the
democrats instead of nominating Dukakis
should have nominated so-and-so Dukakis
should have one run his campaign the
following way I think journalism is best
not one that's trying to figure out
what's going to happen or what should
have happened but when it tries to
figure out what did happen and that's
hard and it takes time and no source or
a group of sources is going to fully
describe it to you and so I tend to
spend a long time often too long on
these books or stories for the paper
because as soon as you get a hold of
that sock on the thread and start
pulling it you realize that it's going
to take a long time and that there's a
lot of thread in a lot of sock as you
know you've gotten some criticism for
not revealing some of the information
this book during the time that you're
writing in other words as a reporter and
having the post there as an outlet that
it would have been in any given time
interesting to the whole debate if we'd
known some of this what's your answer to
that first of all well that you can't
get it unless you make an agreement with
the sources that it goes that is for the
book and the book exclusively a couple
of times I did stories for the post went
back to sources and said I think we
should describe some of these things and
I did if I'd really learn something
startling if I'd learned that say Cheney
or Powell opposed the war I really
thought it was a mistake but it was
going to be a disaster before the war I
would have had to go to my sources and
say I think this needs to be published
in the newspaper and hopefully would
have one agreement from them that it
could be you think that if some of this
information and it's still being
discussed on talk shows that had the
public known that Colin Powell had been
as- on the going to work as he
apparently wasn't at different periods
if that would have made it different
well he was not negative on going to war
what Powell
said to the President and said to
Scowcroft the National Security Advisor
Cheney his boss the Secretary of Defense
Jim Baker the Secretary of State is and
this is in October midway through the
period leading up to the war from the
invasion of Kuwait he said look they're
two alternatives here war or continuing
the economic sanctions and both will
achieve the objectives and that economic
sanctions may take a year or two but it
will work Bush rejected that and said no
we're going to develop the offensive
capability and option and then
eventually decided to go to war so he
wasn't opposed to war he said there is
an alternative that in his judgment
would succeed the president felt the
alternative would not succeed or that
the political consequences would be so
great internationally and domestically
that he would not proceed on the
sanctions only option guess the question
in the context of that answer would be
had we known what you knew at any point
during right gathering this information
before they were actually started had we
known that you think it would have
prevented a work i certainly doubt it
because if i had gone to my sources and
published that before the war i would
made it very clear that that was paul's
position in october and in november when
the president said we're going to
develop the offensive capability and we
essentially doubled the force and then
in December decided we had no
alternative that the policy had to
succeed we had to get Saddam Hussein's
forces out of Kuwait in ordered the war
if I'd published that say in december or
january i assume general Powell would
have gotten up and I
no they would have denied it but he
would have said whatever debate went
went on in October I now I'm totally
supporting the president's position and
I'm behind the effort that we were
making and the book demonstrates that
there was no one more active in making
sure that we had adequate force there
that we had the best equipment that they
were the best trained that all of the
details of the war plan were worked out
to succeed so I think in a way it would
have been a red herring and would have
had zero impact but then again you never
can tell without putting any names on
this as you were talking to your sources
both the high level and that's a high
level what did you sense the people
thought really thought of George Bush
during this whole process you mean
sources or principals involved in this
I'd say prints start with principles
well what the details I have of what
various individuals thought what Bush
said his key decision points are all
laid out in the book people have read it
reviewers people who bought the book and
called me received lots of letters and
so forth and some people have said it
makes bush look terrific decisive
forceful new the moral imperative he had
a grand strategic vision then there were
other people who've read it who said the
Bush White House is not well run he was
not sure that the procedures were very
random that the discussion among the key
Bush advisors was way too informal and
so forth so you know again you have the
best version I could get and it's laid
out and people have entirely different
reactions to it page 3 02 when the
principles matt bush like to keep
everyone around the
smiling jokes camaraderie the
conviviality of old friends positions
and alternatives were not completely
disgust interruptions were comin and
that is a description of Powell's
concern about the informality of the
process at that point in the decision
making it's a criticism it's something
that he felt and there it is you wrote
that more than once though I mean that
that kind of a scenario did you hear
that more often than you wrote about it
or these two or three times I remember
reading this camaraderie and the joking
and the the lack of getting much
discussion about which way to go on this
whether some feeling that Powell had and
some of the others that are laid out in
the book that these were group of man
it's really Bush Scowcroft Powell Cheney
Baker five people the ones on the on the
cover the this is the inner inner circle
and some people come in and out sununu
chief of staff is there Bob gates
scowcroft deputy the Vice President Dan
Quayle but these five were the ones who
did the most participated the most and
there was some criticism that this group
they knew each other too well they went
back in some cases 20 years that there
was not a rigger where somebody would
come in and say look we can do this or
we can do this or we can do that the
classic option paper it was a kind of
feeling for each other they knew where
things were going they understood bush
and so air views were not fully aired I
think I think that's probably a valid
criticism did you become away from your
discussions and writing this book with
particularly positive feeling about
anybody
more so than others well I think
probably the person that surprised me
the most is Cheney Secretary of Defense
that is you do all the work I did you
see that here's somebody who came in
very much a conservative Republican who
had been Gerald Ford's White House chief
of staff during the Ford presidency the
last year of it been in Congress for 10
years representative from Wyoming in the
Republican leadership thought of is kind
of the Conservatives conservative and
had never served in the military man set
to the Pentagon kind of at the last
minute by Bush when the tower nomination
was defeated and janie learned the ropes
at the Pentagon learned the system got
into detail in a sense if you would look
for a model of civilian control of the
military he might represent it he
learned about war plans he learned about
weapon systems knows the White House
knows the Congress made sure that he was
not making the decision say about war
plans in the Gulf but spent the hours to
learn all the details and made sure that
they answered all of his questions
somebody who's feared somebody who's
respected somebody who isn't one of the
boys isn't you know inclined to go down
and have a beer on Friday afternoon with
the joint chiefs of staff or his own
staff somebody who's very business
oriented in the sense of the business of
the Pentagon somebody who if you look at
the constituencies
Secretary of Defense has to serve the
military the White House the Congress
the kind of world diplomatic scene he's
mastered them all here's a picture in
the book taken aboard military plane on
on its way to the Gulf that's right
that's the special VIP compartment in
the plane that their Cheney and Powell
are together do you get any sense after
your book came out that there have you
heard it all that their friction among
individuals who didn't realize they were
all talking to you oh I think they I
think they may have all learned
something I hope so and I think they I
have really not gone back I've talked to
a number of the people and had some
instant reactions none in depth yet
anybody call you and say Bob he did me
in no not at all you missed quoted me no
you misrepresented me I had a one army
person called me and say I got the
number of active divisions in the Army
wrong I think that's correct i did get
it wrong and unfortunately I relied on a
four-star general as my source and I
didn't check it what do you think of
what you learned about general
Schwarzkopf well Schwarzkopf is man who
has received a lot of notoriety before
during and after the war somebody who
kind of the symbol of this victory
obviously a talented man is the book
describes he was at a backwater command
the Central Command had no troops before
the invasion of Kuwait staff of about
700 down in Florida somebody who is
headed for retirement and if you will
oblivion
he was the commander in the region he
knew the area and they kept him he
obviously brought a lot to the job but I
think the book also describes how much
Janie and Powell and the White House
brought to him and insisted that certain
things be done and I think yet it lays
broader responsibilities for the success
and and makes it pretty clear for
instance that the first war plan that he
presented to the Pentagon and the White
House was not this famous Hail Mary go
around maneuver but he his plan now
granted he had very short period of time
to present it and develop at about 48
hours initially was right up the middle
would have been disastrous would have
been something that would have killed
certainly thousands of Americans
something that clearly did not withstand
review in fairness to Schwarzkopf when
he had his chief of staff presented his
chief of staff in the last slide in the
briefing said these are general
Schwarzkopf caveats and one of them
essentially was we don't have enough
troops and we this is very preliminary
and what we don't think it would work
and we're not saying we should do this
but here's an idea page 347 key portions
of the ground campaign had been
developed by a half-dozen junior
officers in their second year at the
army command and general staff college
at Fort Leavenworth these majors and
lieutenant Colonel's nicknamed the Jedi
Knights had been sent to Saudi Arabia to
apply the elements of advanced maneuver
warfare probing flanking surprise
initiative audacity to the war plan was
that a surprise when you learned that no
you often find what was even more of a
surprise that these ideas of a maneuver
and going around you know by indirect
shins our directions learned that you
come at something not necessarily from
the front door our all laid out in a
very unclassified army operations manual
which is kind of the Bible for them
chapters 6 and 7 and it takes the Battle
of Vicksburg in the Civil War as a model
of how to do that what really is
surprising is that Saddam Hussein or
some of the majors and lieutenant
Colonel's and the Iraqi army didn't
study our army and realize what we were
likely to do another criticism you get
is that if somebody didn't talk to you
they're not represented in the book well
that's not necessarily true the number
of people represented in the book that I
did not talk to and I think they're
fairly represented obviously if I get to
know someone and interview them half a
dozen times or four dozen times and
their key in this I am going to reflect
their attitude more than somebody I talk
to only twice when you the name Bob
Woodward is not exactly unknown in this
town when you call somebody on the phone
you worried that the secretary takes the
call Oh Bob Woodward's on the phone and
then the whole office knows that you're
calling someone I have lots of people
who asked me to spell my name and wonder
who I work for and want to get my name
exactly right I tend to not leave
messages I asked to talk to people or
find some way to get to them though
sometimes I do and sometimes they in
fact I would say most often they don't
there is no suggestion of recognition
and asked me to spell my name is your
style of writing books catching on
yeah I don't know interesting question I
don't know whether my style of writing
books is any different from anyone elses
in fact what I have the luxury of this
time a couple of years to do one of
these projects and when you get so much
information and it's new you just kind
of lay it out and there's no mystery and
talking with somebody before the book
came out who's kind of would read it for
me and he was saying why isn't there
more analysis and kind of summing up and
speculation and I was saying I don't
think it needs it I think the
information speaks for itself and i
would suggest that most writers if they
had this data would present it certainly
not literally in the same way but would
present it because it's it's new and it
does speak for itself it's not something
that you really need to analyze and in
fact when you read it I'm not at all
sure whether I can figure out what it
means I think it kind of has to stand on
its own this is the book it's called the
commanders and the author is Bob
Woodward thank you for joining us